my favorite
tank if it was
drawn in goa or in battle and the alexandre of the
cult leads i sang
[music]
brought up in the orthodox
religious faith
i don’t see any reason to change it now think about it and i’ll think about your
proposal
but for now i can’t for today  the moment
to promise something specific
I
want me to have a frequent name
quality that
this is one of the things that may
lead to problems
then the beggar of our promises when we have
it possible if we succeed if we
will do if this is next with a
butterfly and I  I thought faith is such an important
issue in raising children, of course,
kindle and cool in your ear and become
an envelope maiman
affects nora sing in a
hurry and ulcers aries guy
yelled this steven donned by my adra
but yes it is definitely but you need to know
but you need to respect the religion of each
person respect the choice  Of course,
I understand that to indicate the choice to keep
this commandment or to agree
Yes, I can’t drink coffee, but Steven
can  violate the commandment of chastity
rvs steven benson aske river
hiring about can we then it may
have a lot a little bit grandfather ivan he can
follow me the screen .
[music]